if you put your heart and your passion
to something it doesn't really matter
whether you studied this we now run a
global software startup uh you know i
neither have a business degree nor a
software degree and we seem to be doing
well enough so um i think everyone i
meet i just want to encourage them do
what you believe in and it will lead you
the right path
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serena partners and in media partnership
with c-tech
welcome to 20-minute leaders i'm really
excited for this episode meet dana
vonderheide the founder and chief
commercial officer of parcel perform the
leading delivery experience platform for
businesses covering more than 800
logistics carriers worldwide
she leads the global go to market
strategies and expansion efforts
alongside the growth and commercial
strategy within her company
the german-born entrepreneur and
e-commerce logistics enthusiast worked
in global strategy and regional business
development roles for international
logistics companies in europe and asia
ghana is a member of the distinguished
e-founder fellowship program by alibaba
a network of international entrepreneurs
and business leaders passionate about
driving digital transformation she also
co-hosts the logistics podcast series
the logistics tribe and is an advisory
board member of the german logistics
association
donna von der heiden welcome to 20
minute leaders all the way from germany
thank you so much for being with me
today how are you i'm very good very
good thank you so much for having me
it's a pleasure
it's gonna have um i'm gonna have a lot
of fun in these 20 minutes you're
running an incredible company parcel
perform dealing with one of the things
that i struggle most with deliveries uh
and everybody else obviously in the
world uh it's something that didn't
really exist
you know 50 years ago at scale maybe
milk and newspapers to our doorstep but
today we depend on it pretty much
literally i'm personally the belief that
deliveries are going to be a
a root solution for some of the most
strenuous problems around the world
accessibility to medicine food etc but
but that's one day and you're at the
forefront of software with helping make
it happen
smoothly and effectively and so donna
thank you so much for being with me
today i am really excited for this
thanks and yeah i'm excited too let's
talk
parcel perform very quickly what what do
you do and and how do you deal with
deliveries of the concept yeah so
possible one we have software as a
service company but uh we realized
there's so many parties out there that
deal with the physical part of delivery
you know we see like the big brands like
dhl ups fedex but also a lot of small
players but the interesting thing is the
more people that try to deliver
something and we need them because there
was the silver lining of cobalt
e-commerce is booming the underlying
parts of markets moving even more
the more providers we have in this space
and hopefully the more convenient they
make the solution the more there is the
need to get transparency
so what we do here at passive
performance we work with brands we work
with marketplaces but even the carriers
to have them have full visibility on
where their parcels are and the most
important part about this and the fun
part about my job is that we can do it
on a global level
because we integrated 850 carriers so no
matter who you ship with no matter where
it's going no matter what language we
aggregate it all we standardize it and
we can tell anyone where the parcels are
and then you can unlock this data for a
lot of additional use cases as well
now your personal entrance to this world
didn't start from the startup you
actually worked in logistics and
deliveries beforehand in places like dhl
and how how did those experiences shape
your understanding
the as to the domain of the problem that
you're in right now yeah i mean it was a
super good kind of learning experience
to be part of a corporate setting detail
one of the biggest brands but i also
realized there's a lot of silos thinking
right every carrier if we are lucky as a
consumer they invest in a good delivery
experience but they do it for themselves
but the reality of the industry is
anyone that ships processing serve
multiple carriers from a risk
perspective but also from a convenience
perspective for everyone so
no one has really built this middle
layer that helps you to aggregate all
these services to build transparency on
top of it and that's what we really
wanted to set out to do and we saw it
when we started you know in the industry
we were back then in asia
super booming ecommerce market some of
the marketplaces there they have like
150 different carriers but no one was
able to create transparency for them
everyone just had like oh i have my
little transparency uh tracking platform
solution but that's not helping neither
to the businesses that run it but also
not to the end consumers
so at the end you're distilling it down
to this idea of transparency
and the ability for you know there's the
logistics part of it which is how do i
get this package from point a to point b
but then there's just as an important
question how do i
share this
process with the end consumer
that is looking to get valuable
information as to where their package is
right yeah exactly and the key point
here is transparency for transparency
sake it's not gonna get you anywhere
right like we have a fancy dashboard but
what do you actually do with it and
that's why we built this data fundament
as a company but we make it visible in
different use cases clients want
intuitive delivery notification
also if something goes wrong so we do
all this white label so they're also not
confused but yet another bread
communicating with them but e-commerce
merchants can build loyalty we also
embed it on the website so you don't
have to send it away e-commerce people
find that really great because they
invest so much in targeting people to
come to their website if you can keep
them
that's helpful but you know on the
opposite side and i think this is often
overlooked in the industry is yes we
have end consumers but how do we help
businesses to make better decisions if
you're ahead of logistics right now you
look at the quality you look at the
price where a parcel can be delivered
but you never actually know how well the
performance is of the carriers because
you're lacking comparatively data and
that's what we do with price perform so
they basically are able to see okay
what's the transit times what's the
issues then they are not stuck with
basically excel sheets that they report
at the end of the month or customer
service manager saying oh yeah we get so
many complaints but you're actually able
to have the data and to then act on it
and we can immediately see if one trade
lane is slower if the carrier runs out
of sla compliance so we really also want
to enable these internal teams to make
much better smarter decision and help
them grow
now you're talking about
data over and over right i mean it's a
theme that's that's coming across here
stata has that always been a core part
of your thesis into your career and how
the world works
you didn't start from
engineering background or from a data
science background necessarily no not at
all i'm the odd one out i started
psychology and political science back
then i had very different plans for my
life but then i became a real logistics
nurse i happy to admit that because i
realized similar to what you said in the
beginning right logistics is what makes
the world go round we all need it in so
many different use cases
when you know having everyone in silos
and just doing their own thing is not
good enough so we really wanted to
change the industry and you know one
thing i learned on my personal
development is if you put your heart and
your passion to something it doesn't
really matter whether you studied this
we now run a global software startup uh
you know i neither have a business
degree nor a software degree and we seem
to be doing well enough so um i think
everyone i meet i just want to encourage
them do what you believe in and it will
lead you the right path
but still donna it can't be that easy it
can't be as easy as saying let's just do
it and make it work i mean you had to
learn
you know the operation you know you said
you're understanding the magnitude of
data
in in in the way in the world that
you're in
it doesn't it doesn't seem like such an
easy thing to just grasp and say okay
now i'm going to transition and and and
do something that i've never done before
what was the process that you've sort of
done yourself internally or in your own
personal life that has allowed you
to
you know do what you're doing today yeah
that's a good question and investors ask
this a lot right what's our unfair
advantage why do we know this better
than others we were quite fortunate and
my co-founder and i when we started we
were already in a setting where we
talked to a lot of merchants so we had
real access to a very concrete use case
right we had like merchants in
asia that were shipping cross-border
that were in a mess they didn't know
where stuff is they invested so much
money on customer service so that was in
a way our unfair advantage we came from
the industry we knew how passive
tracking works from our industry
experience and i think the other thing
is also to appreciate that you don't
have to do it alone right i think the
biggest task for a founder is to build
the right team around you find the right
people
and in our case we were super fortunate
we found our cto very early on he was
our very first back-end developer it's
now our cto we have more than 80
developers now working for us we have
our own machine learning team you know i
cannot say that i really understand
everything in depth but you find the
experts around you that have a similar
passion and then you solve it together
and and so and i can see the excitement
you know exuding from the screen you
know as you're talking about this
journey that you're on
what really is the most exciting piece
for you now as the entrepreneur is it
the problem that you're solving is it
the logistics nerd that you're that
you're getting your hands dirty there is
it running the company
what would it be so i think for me the
biggest thing is all about impact right
i feel like a lot of people are saying
this but i think we can make impact on
two sides right on the one hand we can
really contribute to the e-commerce
industry to be a lot more efficient to
make more smarter decisions that are
based on data again but like this is
really a core belief and we feel like
everyone deserves a better delivery
experience but we can only enable this
if they know everything they need to
know right whether it's the end
consumers or the carriers or the
marketplaces and all the internal
stakeholders in a business
so that's definitely something having
that impact on a global scale being able
to work with all these merchants no
matter where they're shipping that's
something that really excites me
but the other element on for me on a
personal level is to also be able to run
you know a global team to be there and
be their leader motivate them and you
know one of the things for me um that
challenged me in the beginning and a lot
of people challenged me on this they
said hey you know you care so much about
diversity if you start a logistics tech
company how are you going to do that
actually and i said look i think i i
want to set myself the target 50 female
and we will be as diverse as we can
because it's not all about gender
and i mean today we are way north of 150
people with 19 different nationalities
and uh 18 different languages that we
speak and we are 50 females so i think
my personal mission is also show people
you know you can do it and you can do it
across all departments it's not just my
marketing and hr team you know it's like
my client-facing key account management
team some of our developers if you
really put your mind to it you can do it
but i think the one thing that's
important for founders also is to
appreciate everyone asks you to scale if
you want to scale your team very very
fast then you often make a compromise
and we decided that the diversity anger
is something that we will not compromise
on same as like the passion that people
need to have for our business so
sometimes we're bringing people a little
bit slower than we think we should um
but at least we make sure we build the
right culture and we stay true to what
we really value the most for this
business
and so as you're and today it's more
relevant than ever as you're building a
diversified team and and i'll add one
more piece to the diversification which
we talked about right before um
the show is this idea of you know
credibility coming in and sort of these
tokens like which university you
attended and what'd you do before
you know not necessarily as the most
concrete signs of of of your execution
levels and what you'll be able to do
how do you
balance between your you're wanting to
be very diversified and very open to
pretty much any experience because that
just essentially means that your funnel
is now much larger it means that you
have a lot more work on your plate to
really determine who is the right person
because you're not solely relying on
the work of of of a you know selectors
before
how does that shift how you look at
candidates perhaps versus how another
traditional start report so yeah a very
important question so first of all
we really invested in hr and recruiting
so we actually have multiple recruiters
per office if we can to make sure that
we can really um give also candidates
the time that they deserve to to be part
of this interview process because what
we try not to do is to simply just look
at the cv right if you come from a fancy
uni or you start exactly what you need
to have for this role
in my experience it's a little bit still
the you know old school
kind of mindset of a lot of corporates
right you have to have your mba which is
great by the way everyone that does it
amazing
but you know there's a lot of other
factors that are very important to this
and you know we look at people and we
ask them hey why passive perform you
know i think that's one of the most
important questions and if we don't sue
they see this spark or they don't even
fully know what we're doing then they're
probably not the right fit for us and
uh yeah it's a lot of investment we have
to spend a lot of time on this but it
really pays off i'm very proud of our
team across all the offices and it's big
fun to work with them so i'm hearing two
two key ideas that i'm taking with me
here one is this idea that you know you
do need to make it a personalized
process and you need to give you you
need to give the respect to the
complexity of it and i think that i'm
taking that through the mention that
you're trying to have multiple
recruiters per office right so it sounds
like it's not just a you know a linkedin
resume and then and and then a few video
calls and you're done it seems that it
is somewhat geographical and and there
is this element of somebody a person
who's who's taking you through this
process which is often also more common
to to the larger companies who have
these complex processes which makes
sense
but then there's also the side where
you're talking about passion and talking
about the spark and and why they would
want to join partial form which you're
saying maybe from a data-driven
perspective
is perhaps even a stronger indicator
than what their past experiences are and
what you know fancy university they went
to it is the passion that they have for
personal perform right yeah exactly and
you know i hope to be a living example
of that not nothing on my cv says i
should be the founder but we made it
right and you know we have a great team
and it's actually possible and the same
was for our team you know some people
work for us for like over five years
already and we will forever be grateful
and we will always value them and we try
to develop them in new directions to
keep it interesting for them as well and
that's also something then companies
need to appreciate that
you know before they look outside you
got to find a development path
internally lots of stuff to learn there
for everyone but um i think if you get
it right you have a very good fundament
for your business growth
donna do you have any impostor syndrome
ever
i heard i've i've talked to quite a few
founders here and i've heard quite a few
people who who do have this specific
degree or phd in their domain and they
still have impostor syndrome running
their startup which
didn't get to the level that parcel
perform got to
now you're coming in and you're it
sounds like you're very
at peace and balanced with your position
and you and you're very open saying that
there are some things in the company
that i don't need to be an expert in
how how do you feel about that how do
you feel in the day today as the ceo of
this crazy startup now
well um
i'm the ceo of my co-founder anna and i
think that also really helps because you
have someone by your side that you can
bounce ideas off i don't think i would
have ever gotten this far without him so
that played a big role i think the other
thing is yes i think we all have it you
know there are days where i'm like okay
how do we gonna do this i never did this
before huh but i think that my approach
to things is like i i try to always have
at least a hypothesis so i go in and i
say okay i think it could be this but
then again you have to stay extremely
open to the thought that it might not
have been this right and if you run a
company like us now for six years that's
also hard right because you got very
used to doing it that way but for
example for us we brought a lot of new
people on board you know ahead of
america stephanie just joined she has a
fully fresh perspective to how to do
things and i think then the role of the
founders are to to kind of listen to
this and you know some sometimes also
throw away things on how we did them
before you know sometimes i'm
embarrassed if i think about three years
ago how we managed excess sheets for
certain things because that's obviously
not the way to go
um but i guess we're all learning and as
long as we accept change even for us and
we're open to feedback i think it can
work i just want to loop back um
before we finish
at
the data game and you're mentioning that
you're a logistics nerd and and over
time you've grown to understand that
then it's all about data it's not
necessarily just about
how it looks and the pricing and the
product
tell me a little bit about your
understanding of data in the context of
of deliveries and and what sort of led
to this understanding yeah so if we look
at you know what happens to the puzzle
right now it is this really weird
situation where you kind of go to a
carrier website to look up where your
parcel is and then they tell you oh your
person left a distance
then it's in a sorting center who cares
where the sorting center is actually but
they still tell you and then you know
it's loaded and if you're lucky they
also tell you
when it will arrive and then there's the
interesting thing they're usually wrong
so all these carriers that tell you when
the passes arrive they are often wrong
and often they are too conservative so
they tell you basically it arrives in 5
to 10 days but often they rise earlier
or like on day 5 or 6 hopefully
hopefully but i think then
if you have the data in place and this
is why we are so excited about machine
learning you can actually very
accurately predict when the password
arrives and you can do that already at
checkout if you take the warehouse into
consideration because right now if you
get an estimated delivery date it comes
once the carrier picked it up but like
amazon and other players have showed us
people want to know this stuff i checked
so if you're really good with data you
can stop telling customers your parcel
is in a salting center because frankly
we all don't care
especially if you drop ship from china
whatever happens there okay great it's
moving that's what that's a feeling we
want to have but don't we all really
just want to know when to plan our day
to be at home to get the parcel and i
think you can do that only with data and
you need to be extremely granular in
data mapping in order to make your
predictions very accurate that's the
nerdy side of it but the output is
really meaningful and hopefully we can
change the way people feel about
deliveries which is painful and in
transparent and you never know and then
you drop it off when you're not at home
but i think with data and machine
learning and some expertise you are able
to predict when a parcel arrives and
that gives convenience to everyone that
reduces your co2 footprint and all that
really good stuff so um yeah even more
reason for me at least and for many of
our customers to be excited about this
donna thank you so much for this time a
parcel perform such an awesome company
such an awesome problem your personal
insights and your outlook to me is
inspiring and it sounds like more than
anything you're you're looking at it in
such a balanced and healthy weight
team first data driven mentality you're
getting excited by the problem you're
excited by the logistics of it in the
data and the impact that you're having
later on and you're doing it while
proving
and disproving
a lot of assumptions that people make
and so i i definitely get a lot of
inspiration from this conversation and i
and i think a lot of others will too so
thank you very very much and best of
luck with parcel perform
[Music]